messieurs dames comment allez-vous je
commence à l'intro lorraine n'est même
pas prête sinon je suis prête je crois
que nous allons répéter répéter on
t'entend 5 sur 5 5 sur 5 je vous
transmets une transmission radio dès que
nous avons fini l'intro terminée vous
êtes ingénieur messieurs dames nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une camionnette
sans direction assistée ils ont beaucoup
insisté sur ce détail j'ai très peur et
apparemment le moteur fait un bruit de
ouf on a peur de la démarche
j'ai fait un tout cas pas longtemps dans
lequel je disais que je recherchais des
gens pour un tournage en région
parisienne il ya eu des milliers de
candidatures on a sélectionné huit
personnes sur ce carnet se trouve leur
nom leur adresse et le contact du proche
qui est notre complice pour chaque
personne on a un complice donc chaque
personne n'est pas au courant du tout de
ma venue et nous allons nous rendre sur
place les faire descendre en bas de chez
eux et ce camion faut saisir que 5 un
petit camion à glace c'est ça donc voilà
la personne remportera une glace
d'ailleurs c'est un temps idéal pour les
glaces là dessus on a quand même
vachement bien viser fait 6 degrés on a
eu le flair et aussi on a demandé aux
complices un peu quels étaient les cliff
et peut-être les besoins de leurs
proches et donc à chaque fois on a
acheté un cadeau spécifiques à chacun
d'entre eux messieurs dames l'intro est
fini je démarre ce véhicule incongru
[Musique]
elle aurait l'on va mourir trouve à
mourir les gens ils nous regardent et à
écoutez moi bien on se prend des vapeurs
gia 0 black j'ai ouvert la fenêtre on
s'est longtemps été bien aussi
why am est qu'il n'ya pas de frein bien
sûr le de cramer 1
elle fut maman de caisse non un lavage
s'appliquera mais ça vient d'en dessous
attend continue d'avancer mais je veux
pas qu'elle explose non plus en
surveille à notre voiture zéro blague
espagne des trucs bizarres qu'on filme
ses nerfs elle s'effacera mois
tulle avant lui le ramadan
thierry 1-1-1 hockey non c'est bon c'est
bon fausse alerte alors la première
s'appelle avoir d'argent et ça fait et
me elle a 21 ans et les maquilleuses
professionnelles et on lui a pris du
poids comme cadeau et bah elle joue
beaucoup au jeu vidéo ils se sont
comportés notre complice
ouais il nous a dit qu'elle lui prenait
tout le temps c'est repos au ml pas cool
ça c'est pas super sympa là-bas on de
prendre la pole de ton mec donc du coup
il prend l'air peuvent y avait pas
d'endroit pour s'accrocher
ml on arrive
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes donc à l'arrière de ce
merveilleux camion à glace c'était
plutôt petit plutôt intimiste qui va se
passer maintenant
la l'entrée du bâtiment lé genre juste
en face tu perds une glace nous ce qu'on
va faire quand la personne arrive en bas
la prod me prévient et on envoie une
musique et d'un coup on ouvre sa on a un
micro avec de la reverb ya de la fumée
partout parce que même machine à fumée
et ont souvent abonné aux qu'elle est là
pour faire la fête au hnp quoi on
s'achemine
[Musique]
nous
la musique est d'une violence
comment tu vas bien étayer ou bien des
maquilleuses professionnelles
il y aussi que tu adores et les glaces
ouais on fait une glace le millier alors
ouais agathe emilie s'est jamais fait
une chose de ma vie mais pas de monture
battu mi temps et voilà
est ce que tu te doutait de quelque
chose d'assez jusqu'au passage était
visé mais j'ai eu une réunion et sharon
duff petit copain il est génial épaules
mais bien ben aknoun paul est ce que
postule à une place assise alors et dire
je les note une vidéo de soyeux ressort
à web et je suis toutes les visions
c'est trop gentil merci beaucoup
est ce qu'on peut leur avouer la bêtise
face élevés rendant donc on va voir si
ça maintenant c'est pour ça que c'est un
véhicule très poussée très élaborées
pendant qu'on roule regarde pas la
recette est un genre beaucoup de fumée
le pq mme el puma morne caisse non et là
je découvre qu'en fait j'ai pas retiré
le fameux rouler avec le friec le prêt à
voir des gens dix minutes tu vois on va
s'arrêter un jour ma glace
ml on n'est pas venu les mains vides on
a un petit cadeau pour toi dans ton
copain a donné un petit indice problème
a raison
rigole ça gagnait ça tue beaucoup plus
français reposent régulièrement un peu
bas voilà c'est pourtant bien dans sa
tête on trouve pas de ta gérer bravo
montage était impatiente avec la bomba
bazire sont au delà nous on met bien sûr
avec plaisir poste et drôle a ouais j'ai
bien aimé trop sympa et me léon blum qui
on va voir maintenant nous allons voir
patxi patxi les réalisateurs monteurs
photographe mais non il aime filmer ses
voyages et 4 des making of pour la promo
d'artistes hockey et c'est sa coloc
marion du coup qu'elle a promises il
nous a dit que ça lui ferait super
plaisir dr bhatia et c'est la fête vient
pas de quoi parce qu'elle emprunte aussi
beaucoup l'airpod de son mec ou rien à
voir non alors pas de chips à un homme
est basse est parti à être en main cette
fois ci écoute moi je n'ai même pas je
sais conduire hockey
[Musique]
voilà arrivé d'avoir chez patxi nous
sommes en train de remplir la
camionnette de fumer je veux juste
remplir bien de fumer la camionnette
avant de prévenir le conflit serait
fière qu elle a pu les admirer
je me suis dit vas-y vas-y lancement
semble en tout cas plus lumière n à
satan yamgnane centre accueille 1930
c'est un tout c'est la merde il est mort
il ya plus de batterie dante un
générateur
on écoute ses attentes ou les grosses
j'en fais une réparation du générateur
pleine préparation d'un
donc là je soulève la batterie là
là je le vois il est sur europe je veux
pas mourir après
pas plus moi
nous sommes prêts nous revoilà gordon
jusqu'à nice bon là on est prêts on est
prêts on peut lancer la musique au
[Musique]
oui
les mini connu à l'intérieur on t'invite
en cuisine parce qu'on est vraiment bien
mon père au vertex est énorme tout ce
qui s'est passé assez ouvert se voir
et attention c'est bien on fait la
surprise a pas de chèques badji a ouais
c'est bien là tu vois on était là j'ai
raté ça c'est à dire jean roy mais
qu'est ce qui se passe là dedans c'est
passé
[Musique]
tu l'as vécu toutes et tous et qui se
passer un truc
en fait c'est quand on m'a dit oui tu
attends un colis et touchant oui mais
ian brossât dans la rue j'avais vu dans
le lien tu te souvenait que c'était un
tournage pour le 17 mars après
participer est ce que je propose quand
même une glace du gaz faty quoi dans la
vie pas de chine est par exemple un
radiateur où ça se passe bien ah bon on
aime ça les plus connus de tous ah bah
oui oui c'est la question maudite j'ai
l'impression par d'autres convives tout
va bien ça se passe bien tu vas bien non
et maintenant un extrait de 5 secondes
des petites réalisations de patxi au
plat
vous avez besoin d'un réalisateur et que
vous aimez bien ce que vous venez de
voir contacter pas de chasser son mail
en descriptions bah ouais patxi tiens
qui remporte le pot mais enfin c'est pas
parce que j'ai un cadeau pour patxi
quand même mais qu'est ce que ces gens
n'avaient pas j'espère aller on a réussi
qu'à moitié le cadeau oui mais un petit
peu on y écoute je suis vraiment genre
désolé que tout est raté merci merci mon
frère ont été bons ce fait klaxonner de
partout allez on va décanter
je sais pas comment ça rend montage tout
ce qui s'est passé mais tellement de
problèmes d'un coup c'est la deuxième
personne on peut déjà se dire qu'on a
vécu le pire possible mais je pense que
là on fera 10 n'ont jamais versé bon
directive datant pour l'abonné numéro
alors il s'agit de brahim l'attelage
alors il a 25 ans je voyage beaucoup il
adore les mangas les figurines le japon
kibira c'est sa maman aura qui est notre
complice hockey vu qu'il aime le japon
il va recevoir une figurine soumer
évidemment direction chez brahim l'a
toujours fait
[Musique]
ok doucement les micros on est arrivé
devant chez brain wave les micros sont
hypersensibles par perdre parce que
quand on parle ça résonne il a rendu
comme bouton de la machine a fait passer
mais je vais trop mais ce sera
probablement après la surprise vous
attend
ok ok ok bien reçu on lance c'est parti
là son blason avec des migros mis un
petit diamant non mais tu imagines un
peu ya quoi dans ce camion j'ai jamais
vu ça en bas de chez moi moi moi si la
question est ce qu'on peut trouver moi
j'aimerais qu'on puisse danser plus tôt
avec ce camion
[Musique]
dunoyer
tu devrais
bref je vais dire un truc ferron on a
fait deux personnes avant toi c'est la
première fois où tout se passe sans
problème moi je veux savoir comment
s'est organisé en fait en fait dans le
formulaire est à remplir a mis un numéro
à contacter en cardiologie
du coup c'est un vrai manque d'amis
alors je comprends un peu plus
du coup il ya en quelle mouche l'a donc
à des gosses ohlala fissuré glace est
pas une joke en fait une vraie glace mon
frère open jo qu'il ya trop de galles
également fait vraiment je suis choqué
et je vais te dire un truc pendant que
tu manges tu as glace on n'est pas venu
les mains vides et ton cadeau ton cadeau
je sais où il est je sais évidemment où
il est ton cadeau imagine un peu l'un
est parce qu il est devant quoi ouais
bien sûr bien sûr je sais où il et j'ai
dit ça c'est un gros cadeau
ouais ça c'est pour toi ça c'est un vrai
cadeau
d'ailleurs on m'a dit que tu regardais
un peu les animer les mangas en plus
considérant là dedans alors je sais pas
si tu peut l'ouvrir maintenant si c'est
une bonne idée mais si tu regardes sur
ce côté là de la boîte c'est une
figurine soumet à deux gars qui est
genre magnifique et c'est un perso de
naruto je passe tu connais la route aux
je suis trop content au hashtag hashtag
and ride au chili merci en tout cas et
ce qu'il fait pas un peu froid pour
manger une glace dit nous avait été
franchement non moi je suis un mec je
suis tout en chaleur
enfin on peut écouter coupé merci à toi
mec d'avoir pris le temps de remplir un
petit formulaire ça bouge et c'est une
bonne recrue tu es et tu verras
franchement tu vas kiffer le rendu de
cette figurine merci beaucoup aux cent
tours
[Musique]
[Rires]
trop sympa way aucun imprévu relou le
cadeau on a visé juste c'est un père
fait que ça fait du bien
je suis heureux pardon je regrette en
rien les mots leur de là où tout a raté
tu deviens en fait dans sa foire c'est
très drôle
et quand ça réussit c'est moins drôle
mais c'est trop satisfaisant genre ça
fait trop plaisir on va chez qui nous
allons maintenant chez olaf et il est
schiemann fait du ski technicien vendeur
en matériel de ski et son téléphone est
cassé bon bah on va lui offrir un
téléphone à léo la flèche blonde arrive
à tout de suite là
[Musique]
alors on est devant chez olaf pourquoi
on est raide étant déjà parce qu'on a
bien mangé ça nous admirons fort moi
j'étoufferai j'ai dormi la bouche
ouverts je parie dit pas lequel aurait
d'après une photo non même pas c'est une
vrai pote tu as vu on n'est pas tous
française parce que là la maison de la
fallait aller pour quoi je parle on a
davantage voté que la maison de la femme
ne donne pas sur la rue elle est un peu
à hercules et donc on peut pas se faire
cramer facilement du coin et on est très
à l'aise la fumée la paix mais avait la
fumée ça arrive encore au micro mais oui
[Musique]
et c'est toi
mcdo
du coup ça va mon bios j'ai failli me
fera peur qu'on la porte
effectivement on a interpellé sur ce
moment on y va
on est là pour te servir une petite
glace vaut la peine la glace a
légèrement fondu plaisir mais j'ai
squeeze glasses on a sur une chaîne du
froid à respecter de a à z
mercier voilà qu'est ce tu perds lave
dans la vie et bat actuellement pas
grand chose justement à grand chose
enfin comme beaucoup de monde j'ai alors
que soit finalement j'ai travaillé on
saison fait de lier mais ce n'est pas ce
que j'ai appris qu'il vendait du
matériel de ski effectivement kim and
data combientième et walt tue plus
niveau bouquetins les cheveux sinovel
wind était bien et j'avais été
tranquille voilà olaf on a aussi un
petit cadeau pour toi alors oui c'est
vrai mais il est juste là voyez rend au
plat tu viens donc toi en plus de la
glace mais qu'est ce que c'est bon c'est
bon un peu gênant tuent nos jeunes là ok
voilà pour nous a dit que t'avais péter
ton téléphone c'est tout bon c'est un
nouveau téléphone
et bien voilà c'est celui que j'utilise
c'est celui qui la vivent au x 51 s'est
pas tu devrais être rassasié ces mêmes
parages sa gamme merci beaucoup m
et les files et mal an et bien sûr
hashtag add on pose un plot du web en
sortir au premier merci à la personne
tout mon jeu ouais merci pur plaisir
tchèque du coude rentre bien
[Musique]
voilà arrivés nous voilà si l'abonné
numéro 5
c'est bien c'est mais lina ben mhenni
mais il a 24 ans et aurélie aurélie n'a
que 16 ans et ça c'était colonel ri bah
ouais mais pas une lettre de bon avec
mélina 24 ans mais n'importe quoi
j'attends d'avoir un flash back
jamais les affaires jugées par me pollet
et mélina 24 ans et c'est sa soeur
cellier saint amand qui sont nos
complices ok et alors elle en fait sont
téléphonés cassé comme aulas l'ina a
tout de suite j'espère très surprise de
bien marcher le bateau hôpital en talk
et non ça n'a pas marché
pas du tout aisée mais il ya vraiment
beaucoup de fumée on s'est fait plaisir
à quel point c'est nocif pour la santé
ne me dites pas
[Musique]
bienvenue
bonsoir tout le monde ça va encore quand
tu vois les chiffres est elle passée
avec nous c'est la grâce le plus fondu
qui a été servi dans ce quartier
viennent achètent rocheux suis trop
court pour remercier tamas tamaro il
semble à notre complice sa maman mais
les noms
bravo oui non oui mais ce qui remplit ma
mère est native on vient on descend
d'aller porter des idées des paquebots
géants de la musique
à ce prix-là bull mélina tu va l'être
encore plus après avoir dévalé ce cadeau
c'est un téléphone le même que celui que
j'utilise pour lancer cette merveilleuse
musique c'est 1,50 et des nouveautés
je sais vraiment pas dans ce compromis
mais on va te vois tu vas quand même
monté de trois packs d'eau en mon nom
mais merci vous pourrez faire un petit
fantôme
merci trop c'est trop
elle était géniale a été trop cool
ménard maire on veut qu'elles viennent
avec nous dans la voiture martin blount
a choisi ville mais lena tu nous manques
déjà
et j'aimerais vous dire que nous allons
rendre visite à vivian vivian à 23 ans
il est étudiant pour devenir développeur
informatique à epitech un jour j'ai fait
une lan à epitech tu mets conclu vous
nous dites qu'en y aller c'est sa soeur
lola keynote complice et apparemment il
nous a dit qu'il n'a pas forcément un
matériel très cool pour jouer au jeu
donc on a prévu lui offrir un pack
qu'est mois
bon ben c'est long hiver j'ai envie de
te dire on arrive à les mois son moteur
ah oui le frein à main est bien chaude
[Musique]
alors je sais pas si on va continuer sur
les glaces parce que
elle est long très long beaucoup fondu
lens et regarde quel bouton vient de
s'allumer
messieurs dames c'est sixième personne
l'avion t'attend bien bienvenue à toi
vision bien ici
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé à au bâtiment b1 b2 de vous avoir
dérangé passer tous une bonne soirée
excusez-nous déroule votre recherche est
revenu dans notre camion de glaces
ouais mauvaise nouvelle pour la mauvaise
il ya plus de glace c'est quoi la bonne
du coup la bonne c'est qu'il ya des
messieurs avec l'aide c'était compliqué
là-bas tout ça s'émeut serez un pote
elle nous a dit que tu jouais beaucoup
je viens ouais tu vois quoi lola ou mec
je savais que c'était l'homme était
classé quoi je classe c est gold
bonjour pour s'amuser moi je suis très
bien compliqué rien de bon pour ton
niveau heureusement tu pas les ouvriers
balle et je peux dévoiler on va te
regardes et tu t'es battu ramassage chez
soi tranquillement
j'ai douté de rien vraiment pas j'ai
manqué mon gosse des bacs ça c'est un
quinze premières non merci
jusqu'à cette souris est ce que ça tend
à baisser bien merci beaucoup de
surprises qui sait pas trop ce que j'ai
fait pour mériter ça remplit un nouvel
d'enterrer ce n'est carrément oublié
simple bah ouais ouais c'est trop
compliqué game
merci beaucoup
hugh m
[Musique]
très bien à l'om c'est lors du dernier
dernière cliente
il s'agit de amélie qui a prêté un an l
étudiante à sup biotechnologies pour
devenir ingénieur en bio technique ça
sans myriam et notre complice elle nous
dit que l'écran de son ordinateur actuel
tient avec du scotch lac du scotch on
lui a donc prévu un milliard d'arbres
qui est un pc portable vous l'aurez
deviné mais en plus il paraît qu'elle
étudie avec son pc
ouais bah écoute amélie nothomb
rencontrons dans un instant mais avant
là quelques lumières allumées la
dernière visite celle d'amélie elle va
nous regarder par la fenêtre apparemment
ca sion valais dû revoir à la fenêtre
une surprise et libéral kevin glass et
après elle descendra est là et l'infra
la petite fête ce cas là aussi drôle
avec zac de non et d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas de fête sans fumée
waouh non vas-y tu peux lui dire d'aller
à la fenêtre et tu me dis quand je lance
la musique elle descend pas elle ne l'a
pas sauvé sa tête
[Musique]
je sais pas danser
bonjour on a fait une petite surprise
[Musique]
vous vous en doutez ou pas mais les
dinos 0 il tombe bien vu en tunisie
il avait l'air suspect est depuis ta
leur dis mais qu'est ce que vous avez
c'est votre truc et tout mais les
commandes expliqué à la base c'était un
stand de glaces mais la journée est
passé je trouve que les glaces ses
débuts aux tchèques sur ma tante est
vraiment à pire un million on a entendu
dire que tu as des soucis avec ton pc
apparemment ses connaissances à l'islam
il anticipe paris tu veux pas nous
l'amener on peut pas le voir à le voici
le baiser le baiser jeu toulouse
oh la vache on en matant ward et aria
jamais la caméra en fait l'écran ne
tient plus du tout hiatus quand thomas
amélie je les paie t on leur faire moi
je suis désolé mais c'est pas si grave
[Musique]
sa tombe est pas si je le jette à la
poubelle cela en attendant monsieur
encore pris la boule un très bon pc
neufs qui marche bien cette fois c'est
le zenbook voilà c'est pour toi tu veux
ou tu veux quoi il veut le bac de place
vas-y prenait parce qu'après on va les
gâcher ma voix prenez et bien comme ça
regardez en place j'ai pas besoin de
vous servir d'un caméo écouter et pour
clore cette journée
allez on met nos masques et on est là et
extractions et le raid mission accomplie
et c'était trop mignon ans qui a été
refaite en tout cas c'est la fin de
cette vidéo
c'était trop bien on a trop de chances
d'avoir fait ça c'est genre trop bien
d'avoir croisé des inconnus et
d'échanger des justes des sourires des
rires et bla et des pas de danse penser
en tout cas je pense être un journal
taumalolo si les flics y aller car j'ai
eu peur on cache la vidéo vous a plu on
espère même que la vidéo vous a plu on
se retrouve bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo
merci à vous d'avoir regardé moi je vais
dormir bonne nuit bonne soirée l alto
date va le faire la fête à puce a besoin
de quelques rimes ans alors
[Musique]